i love the picture you took where you
said i'm not too proud to go out here
and take a picture with this billboard
what was that moment like uh that was so
funny colin legit he sent me a photo
that morning where they were clearly
still putting it up like the latter
was still the paint whatever it was glue
i don't know whatever they used to put
those things up could not have been dry
by the time i got there and the funniest
thing is my family was just like oh did
people recognize you and i was like no
no one knows who i am yes
the movie's not out the movie's not out
and there's just people crossing behind
like why is this crazy girl
taking all these photos just like
setting the phone up you know what i
mean
genetic power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible mistake
you had to sit down for a second and
just be like
damn i cry every week do you there's
something there's something new about
this process that you know every
everything like i when we were filming
it you know colin was sending me the
toys
you know just being like oh are we
getting like the right you know coloring
of this lego correct and i was like i
get a lego my very first conversation
with colin was about what it takes and
what it means to build you know uh a
cinematic icon and there there's a
certain science to it and a certain like
alchemy and magic but there's absolutely
and i am very precise you know that
outfit had to be just right colin said
what is her hair gonna be like you know
i sent him pinterest boards so yeah
there's a level of like specificity and
care and thought that goes into it okay
so this is the end but everybody keeps
saying this is the end for certain
characters and certain characters go on
uh
it would make sense that a certain
character would go on i mean i'm glad
you said it so i don't have to you know
what i mean i i just like i you know i'm
really humble so um i don't you know
we'll see we'll see what the future
holds
we'll see what the future holds but i
would love to i think it's an amazing
franchise and a world that's really full
you know we are
dominion has now
opened up um the the scale of this thing
and and really asked ourselves like what
it really would look like to live you
know
with dinosaurs i love my character's
kind of arc because you see like oh
right of course we would monetize them
of course you know what i mean of course
that's what human beings would do so
it's just a really rich concept and you
know it's only just beginning in this
one if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i could use your expertise
this is a five billion dollar franchise
you know i'm just throwing it out there
what does it mean that like you know
like the home girl from jessup is in
charge of the 5 billion franchise now i
think that would be big i think it'd be
really cool yeah yeah yeah it would be
amazing it would be amazing all right
i'm just waiting for an announcement but
i'll be honest
wait yeah um what was it like falling in
with all the og folks being the new
person like and you have a lot of stuff
with chris yes yes it was heaven you
know i i don't think i imagined that i
would feel or be as supported as i was
you know um you know to work with
pratt he is such a natural teacher yeah
you know
very much so like very much so and so it
was kind of like getting a free crash
course on what it means to be an action
hero because he's phenomenal at his job
you know you kind of take for granted
when you're watching this these movies
how easy these actors are making it look
you know um but it's a real skill set
and he has this degree embrace this
degree of athleticism you know and sam
neil talked about this a little bit but
you know what they've added what colin
added to the franchise you know when you
you're watching the original jurassic
parks you know it's a very brainy
franchise very you know and so it was
kind of like finding the the middle
ground with kayla of being like okay you
have jurassic park where you have all
these really brilliant you know
paleontologists paleobotanists you know
these brilliant minds and then you have
like very brawny you know characters
that he introduced with like jurassic
world finding the kind of middle ground
where she's both like an expert in
dinosaurs but also super physically
capable uh was a lot of fun
crazy stunts mm-hmm crazy stuff what was
toughest what was the wildest
the wildest was probably man that ladder
climbing up from the ice lake was so
slippery
really it was just so
dangerous i just remember being like do
not bust your shins to wanda like that's
all i kept thinking
like i was just like please don't
fall you know you also got to make lots
of faces in this what was that what's
the training you know we're like you're
all together and you're all looking like
how did that work that was really good
your cats thank you
you've got more movies coming up to
throw me in there that's hilarious
i'm like that was great no i mean i
didn't have to act much because we had
there was so many um you know uh there
was so much of it was live yeah we had
the animatronics we had the puppets you
know so i i didn't have to think too
much about what my face was doing beyond
you know colin telling me to stop
blinking because they had the beyonce
fans going right right man you're like
yeah they had these beyonce fans going
and the fog and all the elements and i
was just like okay all right right okay
okay you're like there's a lot going on
there was a lot going on really yeah it
was wild what was the thing you learned
the big thing you learned besides
superhero school with chris brown
but what else did you learn being on
this movie was the thing that you take
away from this i just felt like you know
it's really inspiring to know
that
there is a space for performers like me
at this level and on this platform can
we say what you're trying to say yes it
is awesome that we are now seeing
representation on this level finally
we're seeing someone who looks like you
and it's so exciting when you pop up and
you're flying a damn plane yes amazing
it's amazing and i think you know it's
also what made it the experience that it
was is a level of respect and
collaboration because you're not gonna
get the fullness of the representation
unless you're listening to the artists
who are actually there yeah you know
we're not dolls
you know we're not just like we're not
just meant to like hit the mark and say
the lines you know and so there was a
level of trust that really enabled me to
uh flesh kayla out you know so that i
could start to we can start to have the
conversation about what we're
representing um you know what i mean
like that question when you say like oh
representation matters it's like well
what are we representing you know um and
there's so much that i hope that you
know um we were able to do that really
serve the story in an integrated way you
know without it being preachy it's just
like at some point you know we deserve
the ease that that kayla admits on
screen
well said the homegirl's the new face of
the franchise
let's go y'all
has it sunk in what your character will
mean to so many people
not yet
i think the beauty of being an actor now
you know if you choose to take it this
way and see it this way is you get
automatic feedback
you know you know how
your character hits or lands yeah you
know i was like sitting here i i like my
favorite kind of content is pet content
so i'm like watching
so i'm watching this video this very
silly silly video of a woman dancing
with her dog and on the back of her wall
i just see like this poster of my
iteration of nola darling in the back
and i was like wow that is in your home
like that is on your wall
in your home you know yeah and um and
you just don't know you don't know how
you know a character will hit you don't
know you know fully what it will mean
but you do get a certain kind of
automatic feedback loop because of
social media now i bet that you never
thought that you would see your my name
isn't on the side of a bus ad i do not
want to be more famous for an ad than
for my art you're not feeling it huh
i mean
you know what and i wanted to ask you
about that playing an iconic character
like nola darling and now inventing this
new character what is how's that i live
for it yeah i live for it so much of
what i thought about with nola was like
okay what value can i add how do i bring
her into this time
[Music]
you